[Music]
let's talk about the drug use oh my God
the addiction are you sure you want to
talk about that you say in the book but
the reality is everything my drug
addiction the incoming money and the
demand for the situation continued to
escalate at an astounding pace so did
the fame and the celebrity exacerbate
the drug use 100% it was like gasoline
on a fire really you know I was already
a young in Wild careless kid and once
you gave that kid millions of dollars
and Ferraris and Lambos and girls
screaming you know my name and yes men
everywhere um it was hard to turn that
off or you you recall in the book that
you spent over
$500,000 damn on drugs damn yeah when
you think of that number when you hear
that number what what does that make you
feel um I got to just be accountable and
be like yeah that happened that I did
spend about a half a million dollars on
cocaine and Oxycodone you know I had
everything on me at all times you know
in my Louis Vuitton bag everything from
you know a couple hundred Rock assets
which are 30 milligram oxycodones then
I'd have probably 150 uh perco setes on
me which are 10 milligram oxycodones
then I would have probably 100 Xanax on
me 100
volume um and if I wasn't traveling on a
plane maybe I would have some weed and
cocaine as well life was going by so
quickly that at the time um I made a
mistake and I thought it was going to
help my performance or my stamina and
for a little bit I have to say that it
did for a little bit but eventually uh I
became a dependent and I became addicted
on these substances and on shows like
dancing with the stars and the talk
shows um I was always high yeah it was
always high Mike actually struggled with
addiction before his MTV dates but
things escalated during Jersey Shore
from 2009 to 2012 the itch worked hard
to hide his battle from production the
most challenging part season 4 the one
in Italy was very um very risky because
you're you're you're traveling uh AC
cross country and I smuggled in a couple
hundred roxies in in a shoe in an Altoid
case that I I I disassembled a shoe and
then I put that shoe in a uh suitcase
full of 20 other shoes to disguise it
and once I got past
TSA um and then obviously I had to uh go
against against the uh MTV and
production security and protocols and
once they got to the uh bag in question
I said oh I need to put those shoes on
so I took them out of the equation the
ones that had the painkillers the ones
that had about 500 in there yeah and
eventually like I said I misjudged my my
dependency every time I would tell
myself oh we're only going to take uh
two today we're only going to take two I
would always take six and eventually I
ran out and then you guys saw in Italy
when I ran my head into a wall I was
going through withdrawal at the time
because I had I I I had ran out of
pills stop you bro well MTV gave you an
ultimatum oh they did leading up to
season six how was that presented I kind
of was happy when they gave it to me why
because I was running a muuk for years
you were exhausted and I was exhausted
and I was surprised I was able to push
it that far the GTL cast wasn't always
making the big bucks that Mike blew on
drugs he claims in reality check making
the best of the situation that he
spearheaded at friends Type move and
fought for them to get a major pay raise
after season one the whole cast was in
New York City and um we were just on a
high from Jersey Shore uh and the and
the ratings of the first season and um
we were all in a
room and I guess um the MTV lawyers or
or um that that representation handed
out contracts and the contracts were the
same from the year before and and our
contract from the year before was a
couple thousand dollars um uh for the
season for the whole season and I I I
just knew something wasn't right and I I
knew that we had created a TV show that
was um groundbreaking it was new it was
fresh they said sign on the doted liner
we're going to replace you and in that
moment in my life um I felt I don't know
I felt like I knew my worth mhm and I
took the chance and I said go ahead and
try to replace me and I walked out the
room
next thing you know it a
couple couple weeks later we got at like
a million dollar raise that is stupid
money it is very stupid money and and
coming from a kid that probably didn't
have to file taxes the year before
because he didn't make the money so if
you read the first page in the book um
where I'm sitting on my uh my family's
couch and it's Christmas and I had just
made about $5 million and my uh my
brother who was my manager at the time
he comes over to me and he says you had
an amazing year
um you made about $5 million it's it's
time to file and I'm I'm sitting on the
couch I'm swiping I'm basking in in my
famousness I got a Ferrari outside and
then he goes or maybe we'll get you can
get him next year uh and I thought to
myself we'll get him next year and that
one decision that one decision on the
couch high right M couple years later
about three somebody would come knocking
at the door and that person would be
Uncle Sam and he wanted his money in
2014 Mike was charged with tax fraud
nearly three and a half years later he
plad guilty and was sentenced to 8
months in prison plus probation and
community service but while waiting for
his day in court Mike confesses in his
tell all out December 19th that he
struggled financially a sex tape under
lock and key in your office as an
insurance policy in case you needed it
when times got tough and you needed
money I was down on my luck um I was
trying to stop the bleeding I had to
literally tell my mother I had to tell
uh my girlfriend at the time who was now
my now my wife um and I said listen you
know I I I have to do this and once we
started to go down that journey of
selling said sex tape I realized it
wasn't worth it ultimately the video
wasn't released no it wasn't the act of
desperation was just after his third
time in rehab the next year the reality
star hit rock bottom how many times have
you been to rehab four it was four four
yes it was uh yeah four when I finally
got to rehab in 2015 that was definitely
my low my lowest was like a day or so
before that when I did something I never
thought I was going to do which was I
ended up trying uh a drug that I never
thought I would try a drug that kills
most people what was that drug it was
heroin did you realize things had gotten
that low for
him um things were pretty bad in that
moment our relationship was basically
Hanging On By dissipated and it was he
needed extreme help um but I didn't know
to like the level of what he was using
why do you think the last time stuck for
you what was it about the the last
experience in re um the last time I
really had no options I was
depressed um my anxiety was at an
all-time high I had lost all the
millions I had lost all my dream cars I
pretty much had lost my dream of
becoming who I thought I wanted to be I
fell behind on my rent and I was about
to be evicted when I finally got to
rehab that time I said you know what man
like I know the odds are against me um
the odds are against most people but I
really I really got to try this time now
almost 8 years sober the soon to be dad
of three is living his dream with his
college sweetheart Lauren in New Jersey
they rekindled their romance in 2013 and
she stood by Mike's side through his
road to recovery and legal troubles he
you know what he he's always been a
really charismatic guy and a very social
person he's always talked to everyone
always never met a stranger and he's
always been a good guy at heart and
that's really the guy that I had fought
for but now of course he's evolved into
an amazing man and father you're you're
on Entertainment Tonight You are your
journey is triumphant The Comeback is
here it's happening what is the best
part of
sobriety oh God you're going to make me
cry every day when uh my family my wife
and uh my kids we have a group hug and
the smiles that uh that I see you know
it's just it's it's all worth it all the
pain all the struggle all the
sacrifice um it's all worth it what are
you going to tell the kids in regards to
Papa's addiction and especially now that
it's in a book I mean listen dad dad is
a is a g dad is Dad is a a Legend uh dad
is a a warrior and um I think they're
going to be inspired by the man that I
am and the life that I've LED bye guys
bye